يستقبل جمال والدته بعد غياب اسبوعين هي
الام التي تربي ولديها وحيده بعد انفصالها
عن الوالد
اضطرت مع تفاقم الازمه الاقتصاديه لتركهما
في دار الايتام الاسلاميه
ساعات طويله تمضيها ريهام في العمل الا
انها غير قادره على تامين اساسيات العيش
الكريم صعب كتير وما بتتعود عليه هذا
الموضوع يعني ما في مجال تتعود عليه بس
لانه البعد عنك اول ما نحطوا اكيد ما
تقبلوا الموضوع واكيد بصير في لوم على
الاهل انه انتم بدكم تتركونا من وقت ما
غلي كل شيء بالبلد من وقت ما صرنا حتى
نحنا وبنشتغل ما نقدر نكفي حاجات اولادنا
اضطرينا نحطهم بدون ليساعدونا ان كان من
ناحيه التعليم ولا من ناحيه الاكل والشرب
وغيره
هذا العام مع طفاكم الازمه الاقتصاديه
اودعت خمسمائه عائله اطفالها في مراكز دار
الايتام المنتشره على مختلف المناطق
اللبنانيه لعدم تمكنها من تامين معيشتهم
ومع غلاء اسعار الوقود يضطر الاطفال
للوقوف هنا لاسابيع طويله
بعضهم يذهبوا الى مدارس رسميه اعلنت
اضرابها قبل شهرين الامر الذي زاد من
المعانت اليوم هذه الازمه اصبحت 80% من
الاسر في لبنان هي ما دون خط الفقر وفي
الفقر المتقع هذه الاسر اليوم اللي عم
تاتي باولادها الى دار الرعايه الى دار
الايتام لحتى تامنهم الماوى الملبس الماكل
والتعليم والصحه ما عادت قادره هذه الاسره
ان تقوم بهذه الوجبات بيحكوا على حالات عم
بياتي فيها الاولاد كان الحالات من سوء
التغذيه او حالات من قله يعني النظافه
والصحه والى اخره
لو قد ما قدمنا نحنا وقد ما كان المكان
اللي قاعد فيه مريح وحلو ومناسب بس بحس
انه بده عيلته بده الاسره يلي
هودي عم تشكل شوي صعوبات سلوكيا بالولد
يعودوا تاريخه دار الايتام الى اكثر من
قرن كانت تعتمد على تبرعات المجتمع المحلي
ووزاره الشؤون الاجتماعيه
لكنها فقدت سبل الدعم ما يضعها امام خطر
وجودي يؤدي الى فقدان سته الاف طالب مؤسسه
كانت ملجاهم في وقت الشده لطالما كانت هذه
الدار ملجا للمحتاجين لكنها اليوم بحاجه
الى من يدعمها لرعايه اطفال باتوا في عمق
الازمه غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت